so steve bannon you have called us the
enemy
you have a very different world view to
ours that's exactly as i just explained
why we asked you to come here what i
want to do in the next few minutes is to
really try and understand your worldview
your populist nationalism and why you
think it is a better route forward
for societies today and i want to start
with one of the cornerstones of this
populist nationalism of yours which is
immigration
you want to crack down on illegal
immigration
but you also want to radically reduce
legal immigration you are
of irish and german stock your
forefathers came to this country
as immigrants so can you explain to me
why you now think this country's future
no longer lies in being welcoming to
immigrants
well i didn't say it was uh not
welcoming
about immigration you know when this
idea came up of
what the context of the trump campaign
was going to be is in 2013 with
jeff sessions and i said what we have to
do early 2017 at 13
was to say we have to take trade right
the paramouncy of
free trade we have to take that from
number 100 to number two
in issues and immigration from number
two or three to number one
because illegal immigration and these
trade deals are just two sides of the
same time
immigration i'm gonna get to i'm gonna
get to legal immigration to suppress
workers wages okay the the cotton bill
that is the one we support the raise act
i think still allows 500
000 people uh to come into the country
every year
well so i'm not against totally stopping
legal immigration what i've said on that
hang on
hb1 visas and you know excess
immigration
is to limit that so that we can have our
african comm
african-american our hispanic and
working-class community
can finally start to get jobs in the
high-tech space
illegal immigration and legal
immigration are nothing more
exactly what the bad trade deals is to
suppress
workers wages of all races increased
i would absolutely disagree because if
you look at this country
foreign entrepreneurs create 25 of new
companies in this country
foreign more than half of american big
tech companies
are founded either by immigrants or the
children of immigrants immigration in
this country has led to
more jobs more innovation more
entrepreneurship
by cutting legal immigration you are
cutting a source of growth and
prosperity you are going to hurt the
prospects of the very people you're
trying to help
the merit-based raise act will cover
that
until we start to get full employment
instead the the issues in inner city st
louis inner city baltimore we changed
the entire education system over to stem
science technology engineering math yet
we can't get
hispanics and african-americans into
engineering schools and they can't get
to silicon valley
until we start to restrict immigration
and on a merit-based system those
entrepreneurs will get here
okay on a merit-based system that allows
the entrepreneurs come and allows the
growth
but takes care of our citizens remember
economic nationalism
doesn't care about your race doesn't
care about your ethnicity doesn't care
about your religion
doesn't care about your gender doesn't
care about your sexual preference it
cares that you're a citizen say that
a citizen a citizen of the united states
of america it's time that we look out
for our citizens
you you you you that phrase that you
have just uh said you say many times and
i'd actually like to pray because it's
the beating heart
it's the beating heart of economic
nationalism yes and i'd like to
press you on that because i want to be
quite clear on something are you very
clear that there is
you make no distinction between the race
or the religion of immigrants absolutely
not
okay you make no distinction on that
many of the people who you advise
and you consult with in europe do make
that distinction
matteo salvini the deputy prime minister
of italy and the first
big political figure to join your new
movement in italy
he has said he wants to carry out a
census of the roma which is a long
persecuted minority group in europe
and he then went on to say unfortunately
we have to keep the italian ones
victor orban the president of hungary
has said we do not want to be a
multi-colored country
he has called refugees quote muslim
invaders
these are the people who are your
supporters in europe
they are very clearly basing immigration
or leo
racist yes they said that's what i said
they did orban
salvini the rest of this populist
nationalist movement outside of things
like golden dawn and jobic
are not ethno-nationalist what salvini
was saying about the roma is that
it's a way to get the children into the
school system it's a way to it's a way
to take future generations let's find
you just can't have the roma
where the the children aren't getting
educated they're not into the health
care system
you have to look with these people are
trying to make their countries better
they're trying to make their citizens
you are not willing
to condemn those statements of what
those people say
i don't i'd have to be familiar with the
statements i certainly do i certainly do
not condemn
victor orban and salvini these two
individuals these two individuals are
saving their countries and that's why
and that's why they have support
and their coalitions have support of
two-thirds of the population
that's right that's right that's why i
think you are a racist
because you may not be yourself but you
refuse to condemn people who are clear
victor orban is not a racist and
salvinia is not a racist
and by the way the two-thirds of the
people in hungary and the two-thirds of
the people in italy that support that
coalition
they're not racist and they're tired of
being called races they're not racist
they're people
that want to look out for their
countries these are some of the most
giving people in the world
let's um let's think about what by the
way i think i
find i find it a fun defense i i
i want to put this and you are a student
of history you're very well known to
someone who's who's widely read
when you look at what happened in europe
in the 1920s and 30s
don't you think you are playing with
fire pandering to these people
this is not pandering these people what
you have in europe is what you have in
the united states the united states what
we had in
the reason for the trump revolution the
trump populist revolt
your beloved you know post-war
liberal rules-based order what i call
what your magazine or your newspaper has
a fetish for
okay forgets we'll get on to that in a
second hang on
hang on hey forgets
that it is a system of commercial
relationships
trade deals capital markets and the
subject mr bannon i asked you about
whether you did not worry
about the consequences of pandering and
let me just tell you it does not mean
ben shapiro you know benjamin former
colleague of yours at breitbart
said and i quote steve bannon is happy
to pander to those people and make
common cause with them
it's not just me who says that broadly
you are seen to be pandering
to the far right racist if you said now
you could not
absolutely do not condemn victor orban
and what victor irvine and his party
stands for what they ran on and what
they're doing in hungary
i do not condemn what salvini stood for
ran on and what he's doing in his
country these individuals and these
populist nationalist movements across
europe okay are trying to are trying to
get the sovereignty
of their countries back okay and save
their citizenship
sovereignty which i might add in the and
i don't want to digress
the 10 736
word essay in this newspaper this week
to commemorate the 16th
175th anniversary it's amazing everybody
should read it
but i just want to mention some words
you do not mention
at all in 10 000. sovereignty
terror terrorism jihad
crime defense trade deficit
income inequality or radical islam well
i'm very glad you've read it so
carefully um i'm impressed
because it's detached from reality it's
detached from reality
just like you're trying to smear you
were sitting here trying to smear or
bond in salvini
on on a couple of quotes
that has enjoyed the great longest
period of peace since 1945
that it has had in previous centuries
and i look back at the history of europe
my mother is german my father is english
i am very very aware of european history
and i am concerned that your view
because of an american security
guarantee if you don't make it american
absolutely it's on the shoulders of the
deplorables
oh by the way that's another that's
another word not mentioned in the 10
736 deplorables whose shoulders
upon which everything rest it's their
tax dollars and their kids
that saved europe three times in world
war one and world war
ii and the cold war and we'll end up
saving it again i think we have a clear
view on what your
your perspective is on immigration and
what your perspective is of your
of your people in europe who whom you
admire
let's move on to trade because that's
another area i think where you and i
have a very different world view
in fact in this ten thousand seven hours
they they throw was it the the end of
history guy gets thrown under the bus
even their their their uh policy on
immigration gets thrown under the bus
there's policy to support the iraq war
gets stoned on the bus
the only thing they count paramount now
is free trade
free trade is everything that's the new
fetish so let's talk about it let's talk
about your new facebook i think you read
the essay too fast because you clearly
missed quite a lot that was in there but
let's just uh
let's i spent quite a long time writing
let's um
let's focus on trade because i want to
understand whether you think
higher tariffs are a negotiating tool
or whether you think that the country
would really be
better off if it had tired tariffs and i
just want to you were recently asked
about this and this is what you said you
were asked what tariffs were good for
the economy
you said 100 good for the economy
they're great for the economy it's going
to rebuild our economy it's going to
bring our manufacturing base back
so do you think america's future is best
secured by having
high tariffs yes what i think is that
tariffs are a means to an end what we're
doing right now you can see this and
this is why the economy is on fire and
this is why
uh blue-collar wages are going to start
to come back manufacturing jobs
you're seeing a reorientation of the
world's global supply chain
away from china of which the elites who
were all cheerleaders for china that
china was
as they rose they were going to get more
liberal more free market
they were dead wrong okay what china is
is a
not an ill liberal you say keep saying
ill liberal
party dictatorship it is it is a it is a
totalitarian
mercantilist regime
that is every bit as evil to its core as
the fascist regimes in the military
in japan in the 1930s and you played
into their hands
one of the reasons they are where they
are is because of you what trump and the
populist nationalists are saying
we need to get the manufacturing jobs
and take the supply chain back from
china
that is why korea that is why japan that
is why the populist
leftist socialist in mexico has joined
in and
juncker in the eu have all joined in to
join with trump
trump and these trade deals yeah and
these trade deals
are reorganized so yes if if higher
tariffs lead to that
then they're good well you have you've
made that point clear and aware i think
if you'd actually
and it sounds like you must have read
some of this quite quickly we've we've
made a very similar point about china
where i think we differ is on whether it
is
the right strategy for this country to
have high tariffs in the long term and
you appear to think
that high tariffs will bring back
manufacturing jobs and i think it is
very hard
to find a single economist who shares
that view just let me finish
what high tariffs will do they are not
the reason this economy is growing fast
right now
the tax cut has much more to do with it
what tariffs do is that they raise the
price for consumers
they make it raise the price for people
who use
imported goods and they do not really
bring back jobs because even if
let's say apple brings back the
production of the iphone here they will
not bring back a lot of jobs
they will do it all through much more
capital intensive investment
so if you're worried it's more
inextricably linked it's more
inextricably linked than tariffs you
know that when trump was at the g7 and
they had that first day blow up and you
saw the picture with merkel and macron
and everybody looking down on him like
he's the uh
he's the the school boy who can't quite
learn his lessons right done do his
homework
the next day he walked in there to the
meeting he said okay here's the deal
zero tariffs no tariffs
but no subsidies remember non-trade
barriers it's the state-owned industries
that china
is investing in okay that china has
exported its deflation
and export its excess capacity that's
why brexit in 2016
exist that's why donald trump with and
we're on the 10th anniversary today of
the financial collapse
the financial collapse brought on
by the party of davis in this audience
and this magazine hang on and and the
rise of china at the same time
all on the backs of working men and
women of
every race every ethnicity every
religion
in this country and the west you're
spending a lot of time i'm not that's
the beating heart
you talk about you talk about just
tariffs it's more complicated than that
it's also by the way we would go to zero
tariffs of china tomorrow morning we've
told them that
if you go to the white house and look at
the 50 other things they do that's
exactly what i started this conversation
with i wanted to understand whether you
thought
saw tariffs as a negotiating tactic or
as a permanent arrangement that would
help the united states
what you said in previous interviews
suggested the latter now it seems that
you are saying that tariffs are simply a
negotiating tactic
no no we need to move on hang on no i
don't make sure it's not a contradiction
if we need tariffs ongoing to protect
certain industries i have no problem
with tariffs as long it's in the
protection of the american workers and
not the
the american workers and not the
capitalists no you're a protector of the
capitalist
i'm a protector of the workers no you're
not you're not you're a full siren for
the worker you're pretending that you're
doing that's why the workers vote for us
that's why the workers vote for us not
no no they work because you engender a
sense of fear and divisive
it's called the rational human beings
they are rational human beings
we're just going to have to differ on
what rational human beings a rational
human being
a racial human can look at facts can
look at facts and understand what's
going on yes that's that's what we try
to do weekly
because he keeps talking about tariffs
i know you are because but you're going
to have to own this subject we're at
economic war with china
you've played that point several times
no but but your paper doesn't say that
your paper says there's some a
liberal-like trade policy problem
china has brought all forces of national
power
to be at economic war with the united
states in much
of the industrial democracies in the
west that is what donald trump has said
we are going to now combat we're now
going to point very clearly
um i want to move on to something else
because what i really want our audience
to understand is the full breadth of
what your populist nationalism entails
so can we since you've made trade
such a paramount thing of of going
forward your thing free tr
free trades is going to make it a
paradise you can't have free trade
where you're up against mercantilist
societies that are totalitarian
we've we've heard your argument we've
championed something different for 175
years and i like to think that history
is on our side but let's leave it
right there because you keep getting
bailed out no you keep getting bailed
out you keep getting bailed out by the
deplorables in world war one
and world war ii in the cold war and
whatever else is in the future
it is working men and women that have
bailed you out and bailed your newspaper
we have to move on from that and i want
to go into something else which is the
another era
where you you accuse uh the the um
capitalist elite i think as you
sometimes call it party demos
party of davos you say that
state-controlled capitalism
is basically taking away people's
freedom the freedom of the ordinary
worker yes
now i look around at countries which
have
government's populist nationalist
governments in power whether it is
hungary whether it is poland or indeed
whether it is this country
and what i see is much more arbitrary
use of power
an undermining of the institutions which
protect the individual whether it is the
free press or whether it is the
judiciary
and i can't see that in practice your
populist nationalism does anything other
than make it easier to have corrupt
abuse of power
the um i think the one significant
difference between the trump revolution
here in this country and the populist
nationalist movement in in europe is
is around this point remember the three
things i laid out in cpac that are the
driving forces of the trump revolution
of this populist national revolution
here
are economic nationalism to protect
citizens and particularly workers
uh america first foreign policy so we
start together these
foreign wars that is this kind of
expeditionary humanitarianism of the
party of davos could you answer the
question i'm sorry we've got very little
time left so why is do you agree
no in the third and the third hang on
the third is the deconstruction of the
administrative state
it's the reason gorsuch and kavanaugh
are in the supreme court
they're not social they're not about
abortion or gay marriage these people
are but the chevron exemption they're
about
deconstructing the administrative state
what we're trying to do for the workers
outside of some regulation is start to
get into a more entrepreneurial society
where workers can get a piece of the
action in europe in europe because of
the history of europe
there is more uh people that want to get
control of the state
right and try to turn it around and i
think one of the evolutions in the
populist movement
that i hope and i hope my involvement is
is to help teach our colleagues in
europe
that the power comes from deconstructing
the administrative state
and letting the workers get a bigger
piece of the action through better wages
better jobs more high-valued jobs and
more access to capital for
entrepreneurship i would agree that in
europe there is some arbitrary use come
corruption of institutions and then this
country
i think it's more on the left i think
it's more merkel and macron but
by the way so as long as people want to
get their hands on state power
whether that is mccrone's party or
miracles in this country if you look at
the deregulation and lots of industries
it's being written by lobbyists
just i by the way i agree with the
permanent political class
runs washington dc i didn't say this is
an easy fight
remember i lose nine days out of ten
okay
it's just the reality the permanent
political class in washington and they
do write a lot of the regulations that's
one of the things we're trying to stop
and that's one of the reasons i'm a big
supporter of the five stars it seems to
be something that is
one of the reasons no it's one of the
reasons i was such a big supporter of
the five star movement
in italy because they're ahead and their
economics is certainly not my type of
economics they're kind of socialist
but they believed in uh the stopping
crony capitalism they believed in
transparency
they believe in all the stuff that peter
schweitzer and i worked at throw the
bums out that was their basic thing and
i believe that too let's let's turn to
another topic which is a topic
um which is probably one of if not the
most important challenge facing the
world in the 21st century
it's one that i can't see how it can be
handled at a national level only
and that is climate change you were
instrumental in the u.s decision to pull
out of the polaris climate agreement
how does an economic nationalist cope
with climate change or do you simply
think it's not a problem
no i think people have to think through
and think of what the real math is in
back of the problem then i think you
have to have a coming together
of individual nation states whether
that's through the eu because i haven't
said break up the eu
all those parties we support in the
movement want to have the eu as a
collection of independent nations not
like the united states of europe
i think it has to come together but i
don't know how you get into an agreement
that essentially gives china a free ride
to pollute
and restricts the west the whole problem
with the whole problem agreement did not
give trade
absolutely gave china a free ride you
will always give in china a free ride
china had absolute total free ride
the paris accord is a debacle as far as
the deal goes
if you want to come back and if people
want to and president trump is very open
if there's a better deal that actually
works he was very open to do that
as as am i but i think you miss
the threat is not climate change the
threat besides the inexorable right
the rise of a totalitarian mercantilist
china
which is the central geostrategic issue
of our day with the west
it is the convergence it and this is why
i'm a populist i see
the i see what globalism did to the
workers okay
particularly united states but this
convergence of automation
advanced chip design robotics and
genetic engineering
that will happen in the lifetime of
three quarters of the audience here
is going to be the greatest challenge we
face in the 21st century and i think the
greatest challenge in the history of
mankind
i won't be around and neither were you
to face that but unless we
take back from the scientific
engineering
managerial class in davos
who read this newspaper and take it as
gospel truth
unless you take it back with that
because you just told me earlier how
much you enjoyed reading this news i
love this newspaper
i've read it every week since i was 12
and the financial times
i don't agree with it but it's the best
for as far as the facts go
you just interpret the facts the wrong
way but at least we use
facts i think the difference is that we
use facts mr banner
to your own accord um no i
did this convergence what people call
the singularity ever will happen at 25
30 years or so
is the single biggest threat in the 21st
century unless
workers start to take control of the
political process
in the united states and in europe it's
going to be a total debacle because the
same geniuses
that got us in this spot today are going
to be the same geniuses to make
decisions on that
people taking control of the political
process is something that liberals have
always been extremely keen on where you
and i
differ is in what is the best policies
thereafter we have a very different
world view
on what is the right way to reach a more
prosperous society but we have
one minute 37 seconds left before we go
into questions and i want to ask you
uh uh one other question which is
something close to my heart which is
uh the time's up me too movement and you
seem quite impressed by the power of the
time's up movement
but you also seem to be rather against
its goals and i'm a little
sort of i'm a bit confused by that
because it seems to me that
the time's up movement should be exactly
the kind of thing that you are in favor
of which is an
anti-establishment movement growing up
to change rules that are rigged against
a particular group
i think if you can way i look at if the
populist nationalist movement's kind of
like the american revolution
it's about sovereignty and where
decisions are made and who makes them
i think the time's up in the in the me
too as a subset of that the time's up
movement
which i think is enormously powerful is
like the french revolution it wants to
totally reorder society
um and i think it's reordering not just
against the judeo-christian west but
hindu and
islamic society that are all built on
the patriarchy
that's five thousand or ten thousand
years of recorded history the time's up
movement is the
most powerful political movement in the
world are you a guest
i don't know i don't know what the
matriarchy i don't know what the
matriarchy would look like
so right now i'm i'm i'm over whether
you are a plain old chauvinist
or whether you are actually i'm a former
naval officer
that served in the south china sea in
the pacific my daughter
is a graduate of the united states
military academy at west point
and served with the 101st airborne in
iraq she's an army captain today
after serving in eastern europe probably
get deployed
was going to get deployed back to
afghanistan she's on the factory west
point
i know how to help raise an empowered
woman
okay so i fully understand what the
objectives are
and i agree with the objectives about
empowering women i'm quite shocked
that the metoo movement hasn't cut
through corporate america
with a bigger sith because i think
there's a lot of potential there
and i all i'm saying is that the time's
up movement i believe
is the single most powerful potential
political movement in the world
that seems an appropriate place to go to
questions it's an area where we can
probably agree
i'm going to open questions here to lady
here in the front row could you just
wait for the microphone so that
our colleagues in london can hear you
i'm julissa arce i am a formerly
undocumented immigrant
also a very proud american citizen and
i'm wondering
whether you realize that you're lying to
people or you or you
do it on purpose in that you tell them
that immigrants like me
are taking their jobs and at the same
time you are
for tax cuts for the very wealthy and
rich people
and corporations where corporations are
not for the worker but they're for the
shareholder
and what's really eradicating in the
middle class is not people like me
it's corporations corporately the one
percent
oh and also since you like reading so
much i brought you a copy
of my book so you can learn more about
people like me thank you very much
thank you
i would love to have you sign this later
if you could but but you did
thank you
all right and hang on hang on hang on
hang on
the um it's just a fact unlimited
illegal immigration
suppresses wages of hispanic
i know that but it suppresses wages of
hispanic
and african-american citizens it's why
the chamber of commerce wants us why the
republican elite wants it
it's just another form of unlimited
labor pool right they don't mind
unlimited competition
among workers whether that's through
illegal immigration or through trade
deals or unlimited immigration that's
just that's just a fact
okay and by the way in the white house
i'm the guy in the oval office
that fought for 44 percent tax for
people making over 5 million dollars
i fought for that and i lost that fight
to gary cohn and steve mnuchin
who are progressive democrats so so
so i fought for that in addition the
thing i supported on the tax bill
was the corporate taxes were to make us
competitive with china
and germany and to start to bring
manufacturing jobs back here
i'm not a massive fan of the tax plan
and people understand and know my record
and know the wall street journal
financial times i fought
every day for workers get a bigger piece
of the
tax cut what my my non-profit is doing
right now we're running analysis
on my concept of no tax on labor
no tax on work up to a hundred thousand
dollars you wouldn't have to pay taxes
on your work
that the capitalist and capital would
have to pay more taxes
and that's why why do you think the
republican establishment the republican
establishment hates me
10 times more than the progressive left
there are many people many people
okay five times
wait no i would love to continue we are
going to have to give our colleagues in
london a chance they've been patiently
listening
uh daniel franklin let's turn over to
you with a question from the london
audience
yes i see a uh plenty of hands going up
here but i see a lady there
uh if you could yeah keep your hand up
keep your hand up
no no you had your hand up there yes
so um 35 percent of er
mr bam 35 of 18 to 24 year olds
um in the u.s election 2016 uh uh
only 35 voted for um your candidate so
um given that in 15 to 25 years time
these will be the people who are making
the laws
how do you propose to change them to
your ideologies
i i think it's why i come to forums like
this or why i try to
speak everywhere and try to get out and
it's by actions and facts
right talk is cheap just look at the
actions
look at the actions of what we're trying
to do in making this more of a
workers-based
economy what we're trying to do to save
jobs what we're trying to do to bring
high-value added manufacturing jobs back
what we're trying to do to make sure
that that illegal
immigrants are not brought here it's
kind of serfs i mean that's what that's
what for millennials
what you guys are today is serfs you're
like 19th century russian serfs
since the financial crash that started
10 years ago today
in london with the bankruptcy of lehman
what the elites did
is they the balance sheet of the federal
reserve went from 880 billion dollars to
4.5 trillion dollars
they cut the spigots of liquidity on to
save themselves
so if you owned assets real estate
stocks any kind of intellectual property
you've had the greatest 10-year run in
history why do you think this does not
talk about income inequality
because i have to ignore that no i have
to inject because it's simply not true
and we have i wrote a survey in 2012
on income inequality
i'm just talking about the ten thousand
seven hundred and thirty six word essay
does not address that no here's my point
is that
the elites the party of davos took care
of themselves and let the devil catch
the hindmost
that is the fuse that got lit 10 years
ago today
is what brought donald trump into your
lives okay
because he articulated as much as you
hate him
as much as you hate him and despise him
and detest him look at what he's saying
and connecting to workers
okay it's the party a davos that created
donald trump
it's the party of davos that created him
to laugh should we get another question
because i think there are a lot of
people who are anyway
it comes to actions ma'am that's what's
going to happen daniel let's get another
question
we have one more here in london yes yeah
sure um
so we had the ton of blair here earlier
and he also spoke about the
that china poses to europe and the
western world and his argument was for a
strong european union as a block taken
strength from european people and my
question is why don't you support this
idea since every party support want to
dismantle the european union and further
decentralize europe and make a stand
harder
the european union why isn't that the
answer to to china in your view
because i think you first off have to
have and i think that's why these
parties that are rising
that what they want is not a united
states of europe where you have where
you have
italy's like north carolina to france's
uh
georgia what they want is independent 27
or 28 independent nation states with
their own sovereignty where their
citizens
interests come first and that thing i
think that the sense of treaty was
failure i still think that that is the
basic building block
of where freedom is and i think that
they these will these uh
individual nations will unite like the
judeo-christian west has always united
at the end
to to save this off and that's the great
challenge of the 21st century along with
automation and i think that when you see
when when these countries and
there's not one country now for the
european elections of next year we're
focused on
i have not heard one of the leaders that
i'm talking to all the time say they
want to destroy the eu
what they want to do is not do mccrone's
vision macron's speech last year with
further integration further economic
integration for the political
integration
they want to stop that they don't want
the united states of europe they want a
collect
they want a union a confederation of
independent
individual sovereign states one more
question from london then we'll try and
get one more here from new york
um question here just near the front
hi steve um i come from romania a
country under which
uh so former back in the soviet union
times
the workers had power over the political
process
uh to quote you from before can you give
me one example in which
a country uh has the power in the hands
of the workers
and was better off than any capitalist
country in the same time period
can you give one example yeah i think by
the way i think in the under the
american system of the united states in
the 19th century
where workers had a lot more power and
you know a lot more freedom
i think i think that that was a i think
that was i think we might have to
clarify that not all workers
no but i think i think that i i have i
have a tremendous respect
for blue-collar people i have tremendous
respect for workers
i come from a blue collar family i think
when decision making is pushed down
to workers and i would argue the fact
that romania or the soviet union were
workers paradises they were basically
dictatorships
one more question here um yes gentlemen
there third row this i'm afraid has to
be the last question
thank you for coming here today um my
question is uh
was and is donald trump truthfully your
first choice for your movement
was he simply a vehicle so in 2000
i did try to talk sarah palin at one
time remember when i first looked at
this
is this a sexist audience or what where
where
where's time's up when you need it
the key thing for us was originally to
get the ideas out there
that's why i talk to people like jeff
sessions that's where i talk to people
like lou dobbs i try to talk to people
like sarah palin
right no one ever took debate but the
key was to get trade
because trade is considered like
medieval theology
it's just assumed that free trade works
and it's a radical
radical radical idea it destroyed the
workers in the united states
and de-industrialized our country so so
so so
when trump but but when trump came along
he articulated this perfectly and here's
the thing he knows these issues
if there's any one issue there's any one
issue that he knows
it's trade in china et cetera so he was
he was to me the when he came along the
perfect candidate
we have i'm afraid run out of time we've
ended on
the subject where i think we are just
going to have to agree that we have a
very different worldview i like to
in fact i'm quite sure that our world
view is based on the facts which is that
if you look back
at the history of trade over the past
175 years
the world has gained from an open
trading system in the post-war period
the world has gained from an open
trading system
i i'm very sure that a world view that
is based
on high barriers high protectionism we
ran that movie in the 1930s and it was a
disaster
if you
i want to thank the party of davos for
attending um
if you just watch what donald trump and
japan
korea the eu and mexico and canada are
eventually going to do
with reordering the global supply chain
and bringing high-value ad jobs back to
their countries
you will see where this goes
we will have you back in a few years
to just we will see which of these world
views proved to be
uh the right one i am uh thank you
however for joining us here for an
interesting discussion thank you
thank you very much honored
you